programming throwdown episode 48 source control take it away jason hey everyone sorry for the late episode uh we had some issues recording this episode and so we this is this is take two but uh this is a very important episode uh personally i can't stress how uh how important this is for you uh starting developers and really for anybody using a computer and so happy to talk about it again for the first time. But in this show, instead of doing news, we have something kind of like a public service announcement. I want to talk about backing up.
Programming Throwdown 第48期：版本控制。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，抱歉这期节目发布晚了。我们在录制时遇到了一些问题，所以这是第二次录制。但这期节目非常重要，我个人怎么强调都不为过，对于刚入门的开发者，甚至是任何使用电脑的人来说，这都非常重要。很高兴能再次谈论这个话题。但在本期节目中，我们不聊新闻，而是要发布一个类似公益广告的内容。我想谈谈备份。
So backing up is related to source control, but it's sort of even more sort of fundamental is this idea that you need to keep copies of things. And so I didn't know this. When I was in high school, I used to make a lot of StarCraft maps. Because you were a nerd? No, we all are. Yeah, exactly. So I made these StarCraft maps.
备份与版本控制有关，但它甚至更基础，就是你需要保留事物副本的理念。我以前不知道这一点。我在高中时经常制作《星际争霸》地图。因为你是书呆子？不，我们都是。没错。所以我制作了这些《星际争霸》地图。
The maps I made weren't popular enough to make it on a website or anything like that. I mean, this is 1996, so I don't know if there weren't even that many websites uh like it wasn't like everything was indexed like it is now there's there was actually rings remember web rings yes where you go to one of the sites and it would link you to all the others and you just go through anyways so um i wasn't popular enough to make it into a starcraft map web ring i just had my maps on my computer and but for me they were very cool because i the maps actually told stories they were like rpgs it wasn't like typical starcraft where you're you know playing this tactical game it was like all about this story that unfolded you have this character and you know how you level them up change the story and it took a lot of time
我做的地图不够受欢迎，没能登上网站之类的。毕竟那是1996年，我不知道当时是否有那么多网站，不像现在这样一切都有索引。当时有“网络环”（Web Rings），记得吗？是的，你访问其中一个网站，它会链接到所有其他网站，你就这样浏览。总之，我当时不够出名，没能进入《星际争霸》地图的网络环。我只是把地图存在自己的电脑里。但对我来说，它们非常酷，因为这些地图实际上讲述了故事，就像角色扮演游戏（RPG）。不像典型的《星际争霸》那样玩战术游戏，它完全是关于展开的故事，你有这个角色，你知道如何让他们升级、改变故事，这花了很多时间。
it's like a ton of different macros and triggers and all that and my hard drive crash i lost all of it um and like to this day you know i have a lot of other projects that i haven't lost and every now and then i go and look at them uh and it's kind of cool uh and have a little nostalgia trip uh but you know i lost a ton of projects when that hard drive died. So don't do that. Don't be regretting that. There's plenty of ways to back up. You could use source control.
这就像有成吨不同的宏和触发器等等。后来我的硬盘崩溃了，我丢失了所有东西。直到今天，我还有很多其他项目没有丢失，偶尔我会去看看它们，感觉挺酷的，有一种怀旧感。但你知道，当那个硬盘报废时，我丢失了成吨的项目。所以别那样做，别让自己后悔。有很多备份方法，你可以使用版本控制。
So I'll tell you sort of what my backup strategy is. I have source control for projects where it's a lot of small files, text files, where source control does really well. For things that are kind of small but aren't really source code, for those I do Dropbox, Google Drive, iCloud Drive, these kind of different projects that sort of back your stuff up in the cloud. All of them have limits unless you want to pay money. I've been backing things up since I was in college and very poor. And so I used to do a whole bunch of crazy R syncing among computers and things like that.
我来告诉你我的备份策略。对于有很多小文件、文本文件的项目，我使用版本控制，因为版本控制在这方面做得很好。对于那些比较小但不是源代码的文件，我使用 Dropbox、Google Drive、iCloud Drive，这些在云端备份你东西的项目。除非你愿意花钱，否则它们都有容量限制。我从大学时就很穷，那时就开始备份东西了。所以我过去常在电脑之间进行各种疯狂的 Rsync 同步之类的操作。
Now you don't have to do any of that. You can use BitTorrent Sync, which is actually one of our tools of the show earlier you can also use sync thing which is an open source version of bit torrent okay so this is a side topic but i was thinking about this other day people on the internet uh were saying that oh don't use bt sync because it's closed source you don't know what they're doing you can't trust it use sync thing because it's open source you can trust it blah blah what is your opinion do you use both like is there a legitimate reason personally i'm not going to go audit the source code
现在你不需要做那些了。你可以使用 BitTorrent Sync，它其实是我们之前节目中提到的工具之一。你也可以使用 SyncThing，它是 BitTorrent 的开源版本。好吧，这是一个题外话，但我前几天在想，互联网上的人说：“哦，别用 BT Sync，因为它是闭源的，你不知道他们在做什么，不能信任它；用 SyncThing，因为它是开源的，你可以信任它，等等。”你的看法是什么？你两者都用吗？有合理的理由吗？我个人是不会去审计源代码的。
right like i'm just gonna be honest i'm not gonna do that so is there an advantage like do you put an advantage on something which is open source versus something that's not you just go on features like how do you make that decision personally um okay so for me i'll look at open source for cost reasons uh you know in other words like i i got into emacs instead of visual studio just because i didn't want to pay for visual studio and and it just kind of grew on me there. I don't really buy the argument that open source is more audited because although we have this fantasy that open source projects,
对吧？我老实说，我不会那样做。所以，开源的东西比非开源的东西有优势吗？你只是看功能吗？你个人是如何做决定的？好吧，对我来说，我会因为成本原因看开源软件。换句话说，我使用 Emacs 而不是 Visual Studio，仅仅是因为我不想为 Visual Studio 付费，然后我就习惯了它。我不太相信“开源更安全、更受审计”的说法，因为尽管我们有一种幻想，认为开源项目……
everyone's looking at the code all the time and there's all this third party. The reality is if you look at most big open source projects, it's really just one or two entities pushing the project. And so I don't feel like there's that many more eyeballs on the source code, honestly. Also, you know, if you want to do something malicious, you have access to the source code. And you don't have to do any reverse engineering or tamper protection or tampering or anything like that. So, you know, I tend to to i would think for security reasons i would
每个人都在时刻盯着代码，有各种第三方审计。现实情况是，如果你看看大多数大型开源项目，其实只有一两个实体在推动这个项目。所以老实说，我不觉得有那么多人盯着源代码。而且，如果你想做恶意的事情，你有权访问源代码，你根本不需要进行任何逆向工程或篡改保护之类的操作。所以，我认为出于安全考虑，我倾向于……
go closed source um i feel like security reasons i'd probably go open source really because yeah because i feel like someone will have taken a cursory look to say like hey but you know like you said i have no proof of that um i mean but i feel like long term it's hard to say for something that doesn't have a server that's like like for something that's just run on my computer or like run between two computers on my home network it doesn't need to reach out to a third party like i don't worry about it as much and i would only start to worry about it if it's like i'm depending on someone i'm buying a piece of software and I need them to be doing something on an ongoing basis as well. Like that makes me a little less happy.
我会选择闭源。我觉得出于安全考虑，我可能会选择开源，真的。因为我觉得会有人粗略地看一眼说“嘿，这有问题”。但如你所说，我没有证据。我的意思是，长期来看，对于那些不需要服务器的东西，比如只在我的电脑上运行，或者在我家庭网络的两台电脑之间运行，不需要连接到第三方的东西，我不太担心。只有当我依赖某人，购买了一款软件，并且需要他们持续提供服务时，我才会开始担心。这让我不太高兴。
Yeah. Right. Well, yeah, definitely when BitTorrent sync was, uh, you have to pay per month. I didn't use it because,
是的。没错。嗯，当 BitTorrent Sync 需要按月付费时，我确实没用它，因为……
uh, yeah, yeah. Anything you have to pay per month, it just, it definitely like turns me off. I think we talked about this in the last episode. Yeah.
嗯，是的。任何需要按月付费的东西，确实让我很反感。我想我们在上一期节目中谈过这个。是的。
Um, but you know, now it's just, I think it's $50 one-time fee, so it's totally reasonable. At the time, SyncThing blew up your processor. Not literally, but SyncThing would just max out my processor 24-7. And I had some very large directories full of pictures, and for whatever reason, the indexing just wasn't optimized or what have you. And even though nothing would change, I wouldn't even add any pictures,
但是，现在我想它是一次性收费 50 美元，所以非常合理。当时，SyncThing 会让你的处理器过载。不是字面意义上的爆炸，但 SyncThing 会让我的处理器 24 小时满负荷运转。我有一些装满照片的大文件夹，由于某种原因，索引没有优化还是怎么的。即使什么都没变，我甚至没有添加任何照片……
one of my cores would be at 100% and my laptop battery wouldn't last and things like that. Since then, they fixed a lot of that. But I'd already migrated over to BitTorrent Sync, so I'd have to migrate back. But I did, just for experimental reasons, I did reinstall SyncThing and try it, the latest version, and all those problems are fixed. So I guess if I had to tell people, I would tell them to use SyncThing at this point because it's more mature. But when I started, it was in bad shape i use bit torrent sync in all fairness also because it has mobile clients oh that's true um i forgot about that but uh but yeah the mobile client is amazing it just every time you take a picture and i don't need it that often but i do occasionally and also for like you said for pictures okay so you use rsync sync thing btsync
我的一个核心会占用 100%，我的笔记本电池也撑不住之类的。从那以后，他们修复了很多问题。但我已经迁移到了 BitTorrent Sync，所以我不想再迁回去。不过，出于实验原因，我确实重新安装了 SyncThing 并试用了最新版本，所有那些问题都解决了。所以如果我要告诉别人，我现在会建议他们使用 SyncThing，因为它更成熟。但我刚开始用的时候，它状况很糟。公平地说，我也使用 BitTorrent Sync，因为它有移动客户端。哦，那是真的，我忘了这一点。但移动客户端太棒了。每次你拍照片时——虽然我不需要那么频繁地用，但我偶尔会用——而且正如你所说，为了照片。好吧，所以你使用 Rsync、SyncThing、BTSync……
between two computers you own right so for files that are too big to fit on the cloud without spending money i'll use you know btsync yeah like you know if you have like in my case i have you know terabytes of photos um i don't know what that would cost me per month but it's much easier for me to i actually have bt sync running at my parents house so like literally i take a picture with with my phone and then the next time i'm on wi-fi it goes to my parents and to my desktop yeah i need to set something like that up because that's really important uh is not just computers you have in your house because if you have fire or theft or flood or whatever it may be and ever you lose everything in your house you really can't rely
在你拥有的两台电脑之间，对吧？所以对于那些太大而无法在不花钱的情况下存入云端的文件，我会使用 BTSync。是的，比如在我的情况下，我有数 TB 的照片。我不知道这每个月要花我多少钱，但我把 BT Sync 运行在我父母家更容易。所以，我用手机拍张照片，下次连上 Wi-Fi 时，它就会传到我父母家和我的台式机上。是的，我需要设置类似的东西，因为这真的很重要。不仅仅是你家里的电脑，因为如果发生火灾、盗窃、洪水或其他什么情况，你失去了家里的一切，你真的不能只依赖……
only on that yep that's right although it's much better than having relying on a single spinning bit of metal inside a metal case inside a computer um oh yeah that could just go down randomly at any point and you know you'd be faced with either just loss of it or paying large sums of money to attempt to recover it yep the other thing is um this is a little bit orthogonal but i had a friend who uh um lives in berkeley and you know was uh went on facebook and told everyone he's so excited to go on vacation, went on vacation, and then was robbed while he was out of town. And that person, they took all his electronics. And so things he had on Dropbox he could recover,
那个。没错，虽然这比只依赖电脑机箱内那块旋转的金属片要好得多。哦，是的，它随时可能随机损坏，你将面临要么丢失数据，要么支付巨额费用尝试恢复的局面。没错。另一件事是……这有点离题，但我有个朋友住在伯克利，他在 Facebook 上告诉所有人他很兴奋要去度假，结果他去度假时被抢劫了。那个人拿走了他所有的电子产品。所以他在 Dropbox 上的东西他可以恢复……
but even if he had backed it up on an external hard drive, it's still gone, right? Yeah. So I also use CrashPlan, which I think they changed their name now. I'd have to look. Oh, really? Which is a backup service that I pay for as well to backup my stuff to their servers.
但即使他把东西备份在外部硬盘上，它也还是丢了，对吧？是的。所以我还使用 CrashPlan，我想他们现在改名了，我得查查。哦，真的吗？这是一个备份服务，我也付费将我的东西备份到他们的服务器上。
And people use some of the Amazon AWS EC2,s ec2 glacier one of those acronyms at amazon to back up their data to the amazon thing so same idea same idea sort of as backing it up to the dropbox servers although i think there's some risk there that because it's not really meant purely for backup that if your file somehow got accidentally deleted it could get deleted and dropbox this thing too and it may be a little harder to get it back although i think they have ways of doing it um yeah i was gonna say if you like long term there's a there's a dot i think it's like dot archive folder in your dropbox that has files you've deleted they actually get moved there and i think they get that gets purged every few months or something so yeah yeah but like you know it's not really like i always feel better when something is designed for
人们使用亚马逊 AWS EC2 的 Glacier（冰川存储），亚马逊的那些缩写之一，来备份他们的数据。所以思路是一样的，就像备份到 Dropbox 服务器一样。虽然我认为这有一些风险，因为它并不是纯粹为了备份而设计的，如果你的文件被意外删除，它可能会被删除，Dropbox 也是如此，而且可能很难找回。虽然我想他们有办法做到……是的，我正想说，如果你想要长期保存，Dropbox 里有一个“archive”文件夹，里面有你删除的文件，它们实际上被移到了那里，我想每几个月会被清理一次之类的。所以，是的，但我总是觉得当某样东西是专门为那个目的设计时，我会感觉更好。
that purpose you know like yep totally for backing up um and there's other ones too i think carbonite is another one i hear about i have not tried it uh crash plan didn't change its name it's still crash plan okay but something that is an actual backup service who kind of are staking their reputation on like and i and to be fair i don't think I've needed but once in the three or four years I've had it. Like one time I needed to recover a couple files and it worked great. And other than that, I've not needed it. So in that way, it's kind of just insurance. But it helps me sleep better at night.
比如，是的，完全是为了备份。还有其他的，我想 Carbonite 是我听说过的另一个。我没试过。CrashPlan 没有改名，它还是叫 CrashPlan。好的，但像这样真正的备份服务，他们把声誉押在上面。公平地说，在我使用它的三四年里，我只用过一次。有一次我需要恢复几个文件，它运行得很好。除此之外，我没用过。所以从这个意义上说，它就像保险。但它能让我晚上睡得更安稳。
Yeah, another thing that's really important is to back up in the other direction too from the cloud so uh i have a friend she was uh uh she's a reporter for i think the verge she's a reporter for some tech uh newspaper and um some hackers got access to her gmail account and they went on her gmail and literally all of her email, all of her photos, everything. Just gone. I don't know if she ever got it back. I don't know if she was able to recover that by contacting Google over the phone. I'm not sure how that ended.
是的，另一件非常重要的事情是也要从云端向反方向备份。我有个朋友，她是《The Verge》的记者，是某家科技报纸的记者。一些黑客获得了她 Gmail 账号的访问权限，他们进入她的 Gmail，字面意义上，她所有的邮件、所有的照片，全部消失了。我不知道她是否找回了它们。我不知道她是否通过电话联系 Google 恢复了数据。我不确定结果如何。
But definitely, like, I have a Thunderbird instance on my desktop that just fetches all of my Gmail, you know, using IMAP. And that way, if something like that does happen, at least I have, you know, a local copy of it. Yep. Although I often wonder, like, if all my emails just got really deleted, I might be better off, but it's a separate topic. Yeah. She actually never called Google and she was much happier and reached Nirvana. Another thing that's related is two-factor authentication um you definitely want to have that turned on that's good psa within the psa me i've only vaguely know about this i mean i have it but so typically you have a password which is some alphanumeric code but then it's good to also
但绝对地，我在我的台式机上有一个 Thunderbird 实例，通过 IMAP 获取我所有的 Gmail。这样，如果发生那种事，至少我有一个本地副本。没错。虽然我经常想，如果我所有的邮件真的都被删除了，我可能会过得更好，但这是另一个话题。是的。她其实从来没给 Google 打过电话，她反而更开心，达到了涅槃。另一件相关的事情是双重身份验证（2FA）。你绝对应该开启它，这是 PSA 中的 PSA。我只是模糊地知道这个，我的意思是，我有它，但通常你有一个字母数字密码，但最好还要……
have something that is on you or that you have so sometimes it's like your fingerprint which is not as great as you might think because there's no way to really change it and it turns out it's more hackable than you think but then there's also like uh various ways of doing two-factor the second factor is normally like a one-time password. So a lot of people, you see like the RSA key chains for banks, which have like a little LCD on screen on them with a six digit number that changes and it changes in a known way to an algorithm if you have a secret. But if you don't know the secret, then the pattern is unpredictable. And so it prevents people, even if they get your password, which doesn't change, they won't know this other one-time password that either changes every time you use it or changes based on a time-based schedule.
有一样在你身上或你拥有的东西。有时是你的指纹，这并不像你想象的那么好，因为没有办法真正更改它，而且事实证明它比你想象的更容易被破解。但还有各种双重验证的方法，第二个因素通常是一个一次性密码。所以很多人看到银行的 RSA 钥匙扣，上面有一个带 LCD 屏幕的小东西，显示一个六位数的数字，它会根据算法以已知方式变化，如果你有密钥的话。但如果你不知道密钥，那么这个模式是不可预测的。所以它防止了人们即使得到了你的密码（密码是不变的），也无法知道这个每次使用都会变化或基于时间变化的一次性密码。
And that gives you an additional layer of security that people need both um and then there are even more secure ones that do stuff a little slightly differently if you are really really paranoid about it um and i i've enabled the otp for both me and my wife because it it turns out it's actually really easy um and it isn't that much of a hassle because you can turn it on for a computer and it just stays on that computer for some number of days you don't need to keep doing it that's right and that is somewhat of a security risk but i i personally make the belief that uh you're more likely to be hacked from a anonymous drive-by hacking where something is going on then someone coming and sitting down your computer and you know getting on your stuff like that's possible too or stealing your computer
这为你提供了额外的安全层，人们需要两者。甚至还有更安全的，如果你真的非常偏执，它们的操作方式略有不同。我为我和我妻子都启用了 OTP，事实证明这其实非常容易，而且并没有那么麻烦，因为你可以在电脑上开启它，它会在那台电脑上保持登录状态几天，你不需要一直输入。没错，这在某种程度上是一种安全风险，但我个人认为，你更有可能遭遇匿名的“路过式”黑客攻击，而不是有人坐到你的电脑前获取你的东西。那种情况也是可能的，或者偷走你的电脑……
or whatever and you can try to go in and revoke it and hopefully you have recovery stuff um but it's it's worth it to not have that hassle of needing to get a text message or use an app or use your rsa key every time right i mean the odds that you know someone steals your laptop and somehow it's not password protected or or they stole it before it was locked and they're not just in the business of selling it they're in the business of logging in as you like like all of these things are just like when you add them up like the the joint probability distribution like looks very narrow i mean uh it's just highly unlikely right so yeah but as patrick said most if it's very important stuff people you know out on the internet getting your password yeah and if it's very important like if you do conduct business
或者其他什么。你可以尝试去撤销它，希望你有恢复手段。但为了省去每次都需要接收短信、使用应用程序或使用 RSA 钥匙的麻烦，这是值得的。我的意思是，有人偷了你的笔记本电脑，而它没有密码保护，或者他们在它锁定之前就偷走了它，而且他们不是为了卖掉它，而是为了登录你的账号——所有这些加起来，联合概率分布看起来非常小。我的意思是，这极不可能，对吧？所以，是的，但正如 Patrick 所说，如果是非常重要的东西，人们在互联网上获取你的密码……是的，如果非常重要，比如你处理商务邮件，你可能希望它比个人邮件更安全。如果你丢失了你和你女朋友之间早期的情书，那可能会很悲剧，但我不知道，那是真的吗？我不知道。总之，但这并不是世界末日，对吧？没错，但如果你丢失了重要的商业联系人，那会更糟，对吧？是的，完全正确。好的，回到备份的话题。哦，还有关于你的手机。我妻子丢了她的手机，结果我们找回来了，但我们以为它永远丢了，所以我们执行了远程擦除，她丢失了上次备份之后的所有照片。从那以后，我们意识到对我们来说，在手机上额外备份照片非常重要。就像 Jason 说的，使用手机应用备份照片，或者 Google Photos 有这个功能，我想 Facebook Photos 也会做同样的事情，它会自动以某种分辨率上传照片，这样如果你丢了设备，虽然不是最高质量的版本，但至少还有一些东西。所以你仍然拥有那些照片。这也可以算作一种备份。有一点要记住，如果你用的是 iOS，iOS 不允许服务在后台运行。所以所有这些程序，比如 iOS 上的 BitTorrent Sync、Google Photos，你必须自己定期运行它们。如果你用的是 Android，它们每天都会运行。但要记住这一点。所以我提醒我妻子，她必须时不时进去运行一下 BitTorrent Sync。
email like you probably want that secured more than your personal email they could be tragic if you lost early love emails between you and your girlfriend but like i don't know is that a thing i don't know anyways uh but like it's not really the end of the world right right like but if you lost you know important business contacts like that would be worse right yeah exactly uh okay yep the other thing i'll say back onto the topic of backing up oh and uh is for your phone like my wife uh lost her phone and it turns out we got it back but we thought it was gone forever and so we did the remote wipe thing and she lost since her last backup you know that she did previously you know i lost some number of pictures and since then we realized it's really important to have for us to additionally on our
这很酷。它会弹出一个小状态栏，显示正在传输，它会尝试聪明地寻找……如果你在家，它会先发送到你的家用电脑，因为它知道你的手机带宽受限。
phones like jason was saying using the phone app to back up your pictures or like google photos has a thing i think facebook photos will do the same thing where it's automatically uploading pictures at some resolution so that if you lose your device, it's not the best version, but at least it's something. So you still have those pictures. And so that can count as a form of backup as well. One thing to keep in mind, if you're on iOS, iOS doesn't allow services. So, so all these, like all these programs like BitTorrent sync on iOS iOS, Google Photos, you have to run them periodically yourself. If you're on Android, they'll run you every day or something. But keep that in mind. So I tell my wife, I remind my wife every now and then that she has to go in and run the BitTorrent Sync.
从手机发送到家里的电脑，然后再发送到另一台电脑或其他什么地方。哦，我最近有一个显而易见的发现，我一直在我的服务器电脑和台式机之间同步照片，我对自己的表现很满意，因为我终于用了有线连接而不是无线，我当时想：“哇，我达到了每秒 8MB 的同步速度，这相当不错。”它跑得很快。然后我意识到，哦，你知道……
And it's pretty cool. It brings up a little status bar, shows you it's transferring, and it'll try to be clever about finding... If you're at home, it'll send it to your home computer first, knowing that your phone is more bandwidth constrained.
我想我用了一个旧的 10/100 交换机，而不是千兆交换机。所以我换了它。哦天哪，太多的交换机了。换成了千兆交换机。我得到了每秒 24MB 左右的速度。我当时就想：“耶！”
Send it from your phone to your computer at your house, and then it'll send it to another computer or what have you. Oh, I recently made the obvious realization that i was thinking between my kind of like server computer and my desktop for pictures and everything and i was i was like so happy with myself because i finally had wired connections instead of wireless and i was like whoa i'm getting eight megabytes a second sync speed this is pretty pretty good or whatever. It goes so fast. And then I realized, oh, you know,
这甚至快得多。因为我有一个，但我只是用了手头随便找的一个旧的，没想过它比无线快得多，对吧？没错，哦是的，你意识到你达到了另一个数量级。是的，所以我想，我们继续往下说，但 BitTorrent Sync 的另一个酷点是它提供了一种在台式机上访问照片的简便方法。我妻子很懂技术，但即使是懂技术的人，把照片从手机传到台式机，特别是如果你的台式机运行 Windows 而你有 iPhone 的话，也会有点复杂。有了这个 BitTorrent Sync，如果你设置正确，你只需打开 Sync 应用等待，照片就会出现在你台式机的文件夹里。
I think I used an old 10100 switch instead of a gigabit switch. So I switched it. Oh man, too many switches. To a gigabit switch. And I was getting like, I think 24 megabits per second or megabytes per second. I was just like, yay!
我的意思是，你什么都不用做。这真的很棒。你听起来像是在为 BitTorrent Sync 做推销。在完全离开这个话题之前，我还要说另一种人们采用的有效策略。他们过去常刻录 DVD，但现在我想存储空间太大了，很难用 DVD 甚至蓝光光盘。我不知道，但现在硬盘、SSD 或 USB 闪存盘足够大，我想一个有效的策略仍然是下载到 USB 驱动器并邮寄给你的父母，或者把它放在保险箱里。然后我要说的另一件事是……
Like, this is even so much faster. Because I had one, but I just like, you you know had to use some old one laying around not thinking like oh it'll it's just so much faster than wireless anyways right right oh yeah no you realize you like hit another order of magnitude yeah so i think and we'll just we'll move on from this but uh the other cool thing about the bit torrent sync is it provides an easy way to access your photos on your desktop. My wife, she's tech savvy and everything. But even a tech savvy person, getting photos from your phone to your desktop, especially if your desktop is running Windows and you have an iPhone or something, it can be a little complicated. With this BitTorrent Sync, if you have it set up correctly, you just open the Sync app and wait, and then the photos are just there in the folder on your desktop.
你也可以对硬盘做 RAID。这是另一种有效的备份策略，因为它再次有助于防止单个硬盘出现问题。但在这里，你拥有多个硬盘，却无法获得每个硬盘的全部容量，因为其中一部分被牺牲用来防止错误。是的，所以简单告诉大家关于 RAID 的事，RAID 的工作方式有几种原始版本。
I mean, you don't have to do anything. It's really nice that way. You sound like a sales pitch for BitTorrent Sync. Before you leave the topic completely, I'll also say another strategies people employ which is valid they used to burn dvds but now i think storage is so big it's hard to do dvds or even blu-rays i don't know but now hard drives or ssds or you know usb sticks are big enough i guess a valid strategy would still be to download onto a usb drive and mail that to your parents or put it in a safety deposit box. And then the other thing I was going to say is that
有几个版本。第一个版本是……我甚至不知道它叫什么。我想叫条带化（Striping）。不，第一个版本只是把你的……如果你有两个 1TB 的硬盘，它只是把它们连接起来。所以现在你有一个 2TB 的驱动器。一个 2TB 的逻辑驱动器。
you could also ray-to-ray your hard drives. That's another valid backup strategy because it helps, again, protect against a single hard drive having a problem. But there you're having multiple hard drives and not getting the full capacity of each because some of it is sacrificed to protect against errors. Yeah, so just to tell everyone real quick about RAID, the way RAID works, there's a couple of primitive versions of RAID.
没错，但实际上是这两个 1TB 的驱动器。如果你写入扇区 N/2 + 1，你就是在写入第二个驱动器的开头。没错。还有镜像（Mirroring），它们不需要是相同大小，或者在任何方面真正相同。没错，还有镜像。在镜像的情况下，它们必须是相同大小，而且你希望它们的性能相同，否则你会得到最差那个的性能。没错，每次你向其中一个硬盘写入一位数据时，它都会写入两个。所以它就像一个镜像，它把左手边的一切镜像到右手边。但后来发现，你知道，假设你有三个硬盘，当然你可以做镜像，我有三份……
There's several versions. The first version is what's... I don't even know what it is. It's called striping, I think. No, the first version is just where it just takes your... If you have two 1TB hard drives, it just concatenates them. So now you have a 2TB drive. A 2TB logical drive.
一切。但在统计学上，这有点过头了。所以如果你做一些概率论，你可以获得 95% 的冗余，或者你可以保证两个或更多的驱动器必须在几分钟内同时故障。你可以做出这种保证，而不必牺牲那么多的磁盘空间。这就是 RAID 5 以及我想还有其他的，但 RAID 5 是最常见的。是的，所以你的意思是……
Right, but it's actually these two 1TB drives. And if you write to the sector, you know, N over 2 plus 1, you're writing to the beginning of the second drive right um there's also mirroring and they don't have to be the same size or like really the same in any way really right there's also mirroring in the case of mirroring they do have to be the same size and you want them to be the same performance or you'll get the performance of the worst one yep and every time you write a bit to one of the hard drives it writes it to both so it's it's as it's just like a mirror um it mirrors everything on the left hand with the right hand um but then it turns out you know you really let's say you have three hard drives sure you could do mirroring and i have three copies of
大多数时候你会失败是因为单个驱动器开始出现问题。只要你使用三个驱动器，你就可以获得两个驱动器的最大容量，我想是这样计算的。没错。第三个驱动器用于对前两个进行错误检查。只要只有一个驱动器有问题，你就能保留所有数据。你可以取出坏掉的硬盘，换上一个新的，它基本上会重建数据，然后你就会回到完全保护状态。没错，如果你丢失了两个硬盘，你就有麻烦了，但这种情况发生的几率远低于……
everything um but statistically that's kind of overkill. So if you kind of do some probability theory, you can get 95% redundancy or you can guarantee that two or more drives have to fail within a few minutes. You can make that guarantee um without having to sacrifice so much of your disk space and so that's where these sort of raid five and uh i think there's other ones but raid five is the most common yeah so what you're saying is the chances
即使你完全镜像了两个，你也会处于同样的情况。如果你完全镜像了三个，那很好，但你有三个硬盘，却只有三分之一的空间，对吧？没错，这是一个低效的系统。所以是的，我完全镜像了。我只有两个驱动器。我其实在考虑再买两个驱动器。
are most of the time you'll fail because a single drive starts to have a problem and as long as if if you use three drives you can get the most of the capacity of two drives, I think is how it works out. Right. And the third drive is used for kind of error checking the first two. And then as long as if only one drive has an issue, you get to keep all your data. You can take away the bad, you know, sick hard drive and put in a new one and it'll essentially rebuild it and then you'll be back to full protection exactly if you lose two hard drives though you have a problem but the chances of that happening are you know far less and even if you
在这种情况下，也许我会转用 RAID 5。一旦你选择了 RAID，切换到另一个其实有点难。我想你必须清除所有数据，然后再把它们弄回来。但是的，这绝对能保护你免受硬盘故障的影响。还有，我知道 Linux 有一些文件系统……
had them fully mirrored just two you would be in the same. And if you had three fully mirrored, well, that's great, but you have three hard drives, but only one third the space, right? Exactly. That's an inefficient system. So yeah, I have fully mirrored. I only have two drives. I'm thinking actually about buying another two drives.
我最近读到过，它试图处理一些网络附加存储（NAS）的原因，它不是在硬件层处理，操作系统实际上只看到一个驱动器，但它试图在文件系统层处理它。
And so in that case, maybe I'll go to a RAID 5. It's actually kind of hard once you pick a RAID, you know, to switch to another one. I think you have to just, you know, like purge all of the data and then bring it all back. But yeah, that's definitely, that protects you from hard drive failure. There are also, I know Linux has some file system stuff
比如你有一个磁盘池，某些东西用于奇偶校验，它们试图在放置位置上变得聪明，这样你就可以在没有问题的情况下添加或移除驱动器。有点像 Hadoop 文件系统或 Google 文件系统之类的，但只在一台电脑上。这听起来很正式，但我会把它作为一个行动项去研究一下，下次也许能给我们带来更好的信息。
I was reading about recently that tries to handle some of this for kind of like network attached storage reasons where it's not handled at the per se, just like the array might want to be handled at the hardware layer and OS actually just sees a single drive, but actually try to handle it at like the file system layer.
这只是猜测。一个行动。行动，酷。或者我们会分发它，外面肯定有人知道这个，也许他们可以写信告诉我们。是的，如果有人知道某种像 Hadoop 文件系统那样的东西，你可以字面意义上地插入一个硬盘，你的文件系统就会神奇地变大，让我们知道，那会很棒，那会非常非常棒。是的，酷。好的，现在是“本期书目”时间。我的书目是《Kobolds Ate My Baby》（狗头人吃了我的宝宝），它真的很有趣。它绝版了一段时间，他们又把它带回来了，非常兴奋。我其实之前盗版过这个，因为它绝版了，我真的买不到副本。我的意思是，是的，所以它一重新印刷，我就……
But like where you have a disk pool, something is used for parity and they try to kind of be smart about where they stick where so that you can kind of just add or take away drives without having issues. Kind of like a Hadoop file system or like a Google file system or something like that, but only on one computer. This sounds really formal, but I'll take an action item to look into that and maybe try to get us better information next time.
买了一本，我非常满意。他们称之为“啤酒与椒盐卷饼”RPG。如果你不知道，有视频游戏 RPG，但也有真正的角色扮演游戏，你们都坐在桌子旁，有一套规则，有一个人仲裁所有这些规则，其他人必须扮演这些角色。规则的一部分鼓励你承担各种角色的性格。所以这个特别之处在于，每个人都是一个狗头人。等等，不仅仅是性格。我想只是性格。
It's just speculation. An action. action cool or we'll distribute it someone out there has to know about this maybe they can write in and tell us yeah if someone knows about some type of like you know hadoop file system like thing where you can literally just pop in a hard drive and your your file system magically gets bigger um let us know that'd be awesome um that'd be that'd be really really fantastic yes cool um okay so time for book of the show show my book of the show is uh kobolds ate my baby um it's really fun it's a uh it was out of print for a while they brought it back really excited about that i actually i had pirated this because it was out of print and i literally could not get a copy and i was well i mean yeah so as soon as it went back in print i
是性格？还是人格？人格和性格。哦，是性格？好的。总之。抱歉。不，是性格。好的，总之。抱歉。不，没关系，学到了新东西。所以，在这个狗头人之年，你必须吃掉这个宝宝。吃掉宝宝非常难，你总是以各种搞笑的方式失败。但你知道，希望你比任何人都更接近宝宝。一路上有一堆小规则，让它玩起来很有趣，特别是对于那些可能不喜欢 RPG 的人。有一个规则是……
bought a copy i'm very satisfied uh it's it they call it a beer and pretzels rpg uh if you don't know like there's there's video game rpgs but there's also true sort of role-playing games where you all sit around at a table and there's sort of this set of rules and there's one person who arbitrates um all of these rules and uh and everyone else has to sort of play these characters. And part of the rule sort of encourages you to, you know, assume the persona or persona of various characters, right? So this one in particular, every person is a kobold. Wait, it's not just personas. I think it's just personas.
每当有人说“King Torg”（托格国王）时，每个人都必须说“All hail King Torg”（向托格国王致敬）。如果你不这样做，你就死了，你的角色就死了。所以你只是用这种有趣的方式让别人死掉之类的。这只是一堆类似这样有趣的事情，它们都被整合进了一个游戏里。强烈推荐，非常好。我想我从来没玩过纸笔 RPG。我真的尝试过一两次，比如多年前我买过《星球大战》新手指南，当时他们有 RPG，我试着和我兄弟玩，但我们从来没真正理解或做对。所以是的，我玩过一点 D&D，当时我们在学校玩，学校竟然禁止了它。我们只玩了两次。
It's personas? Or it's persona? Persona and personas. Oh, it's personas? Okay. Anyway. Sorry. No, it's personas okay anyway sorry so no it's fine learn something new uh so uh in this year of kobold um you have to sort of eat this baby uh it's very hard to eat the baby you always end up failing in just hilarious ways um but you know hopefully you get closer to the baby than anybody else um and uh uh along the way there's a bunch of little rules that make it kind of fun to play especially people who aren't might not be into rpgs um there's one where
当时有一种歇斯底里。是的，但那是它与巫术和各种疯狂行为联系在一起的时代。所以它被禁止了。老实说，我从来没真正享受过 D&D。我只喜欢讽刺、有趣、半开玩笑的纸笔 RPG。像《Kobolds Ate My Baby》就是其中之一，还有《Paranoia》RPG 是另一个。但任何严肃的纸笔 RPG，我就是无法投入。所以是的，我从来没玩过任何那种。哦，你应该试试这个。我想我错过了什么，因为它……
um anytime someone says king torg everyone has to say all hail king torg if you don't you die your character dies um and so you just use that in funny ways to get people killed and things like that um it's just a bunch of like kind of like funny things like that they've all rolled up into one game uh highly recommended very nice i don't think i've actually ever played a pen and paper rpg before i've really tried to do it once or twice like i got like a star wars beginner's guide many years ago when they had like an rpg and tried to play it like with my brother and like we never really understood or did it right so yeah i i played dnd a a little bit, and then we were playing it in school, and the school actually banned it. We only played it twice.
是的，但你必须有……所有这些的问题是你不能只有一个人，甚至两个人真的不够。它真的需要一群人。没错，是的，我没有那么多朋友。好的，总之，继续。我的书目是布兰登·桑德森的《Firefight》（火线）。这是……哦不，哦不，我刚才把它忘了，我得查一下。总之，这是他上一本书的续集，那本书叫《Steelheart》（钢铁之心）。找到了，谢谢亚马逊。《Steelheart》是这个宇宙的第一部，我想这是一个系列，他们称之为“Reckoners”（清算人）。这是一个超级英雄宇宙，有人拥有超能力，但它不像漫威或 DC 的超能力。这是一个关于超能力是什么以及意味着什么的有趣视角。这些超能力……你知道，人们……
There was, like, a hysteria. Yeah, but it was that time where it was, like, associated with witchcraft and all sorts of craziness. So it got banned. To be honest, I never really enjoyed it, the D&D. I only really like pen and paper RPGs that are are satirical and and and funny and and and sort of tongue-in-cheek um like cobalt date my baby is one of these paranoia rpgs another one but but any of the pen and paper rpgs that are serious i just can't get into it so yeah i just never played any of them oh you should try this i guess i'm missing out like it
拥有超能力后一定要改变吗？总之，这是一本很轻松的书，非常有趣。你显然应该先读第一本《Steelheart》，如果你读过那本（那是之前的推荐），这是续集《Firefight》。我也非常喜欢它，虽然比第一本稍微不同，但依然非常有趣。这是一个很好的机会来插播广告：如果你想支持这个播客，你可以在 Audible 上听《Firefight》，通过访问 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得一个月的免费 Audible 会员，这意味着……
yeah but you have to have the problem with all this you can't just be one person or even want two people really like it really needs to be a group of people that's right yeah yeah i don't have that many friends okay anyways moving on my my book of the show is firefight by brandon sanderson this is the sequel to uh oh no oh no i just it dropped out of my head i have to look it up anyways it's a sequel to his previous uh book that is called steelheart there we go thank you amazon and steelheart is the first in this i guess universe uh i think there is a series they're calling it the reckoners and it's kind of a superhero universe there are people with superpowers but it's not like marvel or dc superpowers they and it's an interesting take on what superpowers are and what it means and uh these superpowers kind of you know like do people
你会得到一个积分。用一个积分，你可以下载他们拥有的许多许多书中的任何一本。我其实自己付费订阅了 Audible，在通勤时听，因为我的通勤很糟糕。我喜欢听科幻小说。所以我读了很多科幻书，我都在 Audible 上听。我真的很喜欢。你可以免费获得一个月的订阅，之后……
necessarily have to change by having superpowers anyways it's a pretty light read it's it's lots of fun um you should obviously probably read the first one steelheart first and if you which was a previous recommendation if you read that one this is a psycho on firefight i also really enjoyed it um a little different uh kind of book than the first one but very fun nonetheless uh and this is a good opportunity to show for a plug that uh uh, if you would like to help support the podcast, uh, you can listen to firefight on audible by going to audible trial.com slash programming throw down, and you can get a free month at audible, which
他们会向你收费。但如果你不想被收费，只需在第一本书之后取消，你就可以保留它。因为即使像 Jason 说的，如果你不喜欢按月付费（我也不喜欢被束缚），好消息是你仍然可以保留你用积分购买的所有书。所以你不需要一直付费。对我来说，按月付费比直接购买要便宜。是的，有声书非常贵。是的，它们确实可以很贵，这说得通。我的意思是，如果你想想一部电影，我想它的制作成本要高得多，只有两三个小时，但……
means you get a credit. And for one credit, you can download like any of the many, many books they have. I actually pay for audible on my own and listen to it on my commute because my commute stinks. And I like to listen to sci-fi. So I make it through a lot of sci-fi books and I listened to them on audible. I really enjoy it. You can get a one month subscription for free after that.
一本有声书很容易达到 10、20、30 个小时。我现在听的那本书是三合一的，有 65 个小时。哦，哇。哇。那就像一周的通勤时间。没错。不，等等。算算那个数学。等等，60 个小时。
They'll charge you. But if you don't want it to be charged, just cancel after your first book and you can get to keep it because even if you like jason said if you don't like paying month to month which i also don't like being committed to the nice thing is you still get to keep all your books um that you've bought with your credit so you don't have to keep paying um and the paying for me works out month to month cheaper than you know buying it straight up or whatever yeah audio is very expensive yeah they really can be which makes sense i mean if you think about like a movie is well i guess it's a lot more production just like two hours three hours but
那可能是一个月的通勤时间，对吧？是的。不，甚至更多。因为如果你说有 20 个工作日。哦，没错。是的，只在工作时。总之。
an audio book can easily be 10 20 30 hours so the book i'm listening to now is three books in one and it's 65 hours. Oh, wow. Wow. So that's like a week of commuting. Right. No, that's. Oh, wait. Go to that math. Wait, 60 hours.
酷。这很多。我很享受。它帮我打发时间。没错。我只是说它帮我打发时间。我们也在 Patreon 上，这很酷。如果你想支持这个节目，你可以捐赠给我们的 Patreon，并且……
That's probably a month of commuting, right? Yeah. Yeah. No, even more than that. Because if you say there's like 20 work days. Oh, right. Yeah, only at work. Anyways.
每次我们制作节目时，我都会自动进行捐赠，这是他们那里一个非常酷的设置。所以一定要去看看。我们绝对感谢你们的捐赠，那是我们维持节目运行的方式。是的，你们一直都很好。
Cool. It's a lot. I enjoy it. It helps me pass the time. Yep. I'm just saying it helps me pass the time. We're also on Patreon, which is pretty cool. If you want to support the show, you can donate to our Patreon and
酷。这确实很多。我很享受。它能帮我打发时间。是的。我只是说它能帮我打发时间。我们也在Patreon上，这很酷。如果你想支持这个节目，你可以捐赠给我们的Patreon，
every time we produce a show I will kind of automatically make a donation which is like a pretty cool setup they have there so definitely check that out we definitely appreciate your donations that's how we keep the lights on yeah and you guys have been really good
每次我们制作节目时，我都会自动进行捐赠，他们那里的设置非常棒，所以一定要去看看。我们非常感谢你们的捐赠，那是我们维持运营的方式，是的，你们一直都做得很好。
about supporting us and embracing our stuff a couple people have written in and like hey like what's the deal but you know like if you don't want to don't like it's fine like we don't require you to do that we're not gonna charge people to download the podcast yeah a couple people said you know they want to support the show but they they they you know don't uh uh you know they're not in a position financially to do that and things like that and don't worry about it man i mean we're gonna we're gonna do this show and if you can support that's great and if not um you know if this show helps you uh that's really
关于支持我们和拥抱我们的内容，有几个人写信来问“这到底是怎么回事”，但你知道，如果你不想支持，或者不喜欢，那也没关系，我们并不强求，我们也不会向下载播客的人收费。是的，有几个人说他们想支持节目，但他们在经济上力不从心之类的，别担心，伙计。我的意思是，我们会继续做这个节目，如果你能支持那很好，如果不能，嗯，如果这个节目对你有帮助，那才是最重要的。
what what what it means you know that's really what we're doing it for is to is to help people out and uh i don't feel like there's any pressure or anything like that you know and if you don't like an episode just download it and then turn it off and you can feel good about really pressing that delete button really hard yeah that's right you can use the what is it on the new iphone the force touch oh the force touch and just like if you press it hard enough uh one of us will get punched. Delete with a grudge. Oh, man. It's the time for Tool of the Show.
这才是我们做节目的初衷，就是为了帮助别人。我觉得没有任何压力，如果你不喜欢某一集，下载下来关掉就行了，你可以心安理得地用力按下删除键。没错，你可以用那个什么，新iPhone上的Force Touch，用力按下去，我们其中一个人就会被“打”一拳。带着怨气删除。天哪。现在是“本期工具”时间。
My tool of the show is Qt. I'm sure a lot of people know what this is. It is a cross-platform GUI framework. It does more than GUI. It does like threading and things like that, but basically You know C++ Has a lot of sort of native thing. I mean if you want to do Linux you're doing some kind of GTK kind of thing if you're on Windows you're using I don't even know I guess Microsoft foundation classes or whatever they have now. I get some kind of dotnet thing
我本期的工具是Qt。我相信很多人都知道它。它是一个跨平台的GUI框架。它不仅仅能做GUI，还能处理线程之类的事情，但基本上，你知道C++有很多原生东西。我的意思是，如果你想做Linux开发，你得用GTK之类的东西；如果你在Windows上，你用的是——我甚至不知道，大概是微软基础类库（MFC）或者他们现在有的什么东西。我猜是某种.net的东西。
If you're on if you're on Mac, you're using Cocoa or Carbon. There's a bunch of different platform specific things. And so if you want to make a cool desktop app, like if you take any of these cross platform desktop apps, like Steam for example, Steam uses QT. So that way they can write the code once and it runs on Linux, it runs on Mac, it runs on Windows, and in all three of them, it looks reasonable.
如果你在Mac上，你用的是Cocoa或Carbon。有很多特定于平台的工具。所以如果你想做一个很酷的桌面应用，比如你看看这些跨平台桌面应用，像Steam，Steam就用了Qt。这样他们就可以编写一次代码，然后在Linux、Mac和Windows上运行，而且在这三个平台上看起来都还不错。
Qt differs from WXWidgets, which is one I recommended earlier in an earlier episode. WXWidgets actually takes your code and transforms it into something native. So in other words, you build some form in WX widgets, and when you compile your code for OS X, you end up with Cocoa code. So it feels like you built a native app.
Qt与WXWidgets不同，后者是我在之前的一期节目中推荐过的。WXWidgets实际上是获取你的代码并将其转换为原生代码。换句话说，你在WXWidgets中构建了一个表单，当你为OS X编译代码时，最终得到的是Cocoa代码。所以它感觉就像你构建了一个原生应用。
Qt is different. Qt sort of has a layer in between, and Qt's goal is to try to give a uniform experience across all the different platforms so that's the difference like wx which wants you to give a native but different experience on each platform and qt tries to give you a uniform experience on each platform but it doesn't feel native it turns out in my opinion Qt is way better. The reason is I've used WX widgets, it sounds great in theory, the idea that people think you built the app just for them or just for their OS, but in practice people know.
Qt则不同。Qt中间有一层，它的目标是试图在所有不同平台上提供统一的体验，这就是区别。WXWidgets希望你在每个平台上提供原生但不同的体验，而Qt试图在每个平台上提供统一的体验，虽然它感觉不那么“原生”。在我看来，Qt要好得多。原因是我用过WXWidgets，理论上听起来很棒，人们会觉得你是专门为他们或他们的操作系统构建的应用，但实际上人们一眼就能看出来。
You'll end up with a button where on Linux the button doesn't fit right but you don't have time to adjust it for all the different OSs. Or on OS X, you use a pull-down menu in a weird way where you wouldn't have done that. And so I feel like it's almost an uncanny valley where it's using native widgets, but it's not laying them out in a way that that that makes sense or there's some weird word wrapping and actually it's actually worse than than just doing qt and people know
你会遇到这样的情况：在Linux上按钮显示不正常，但你没时间为所有不同的操作系统去调整它。或者在OS X上，你以一种奇怪的方式使用了下拉菜单，而这本不该那样做。所以我感觉这几乎是一种“恐怖谷”效应，它使用了原生组件，但布局方式不合理，或者出现了一些奇怪的换行，实际上这比直接用Qt还要糟糕，而且人们一眼就能看出来。
up front that this is going to be a different experience than than a native app um i think it's great highly recommend you guys check it out if you're doing any kind of c++ gui work which i just generally try to avoid yeah yeah I mean if you're gonna do it's necessary this necessary and I appreciate the people who do it I just yeah yeah if you're gonna do a quick GUI for some small project use like R or something or IPython notebook but if you really have to build a GUI use Qt my tool of the show surprise is a game this one is an ios game i i keep i should look up every time but i always forget whether there's an android version of it or not um i'll check yep and so this game is called wayward souls it's a roguelike and it uh is very
这会带来与原生应用不同的体验。我认为它很棒，如果你在做任何C++ GUI工作，我强烈建议你们去看看，虽然我通常尽量避免做GUI。是的，我的意思是，如果必须做，那也是必要的，我很感谢那些做GUI的人。我只是觉得，如果你只是为了某个小项目做一个快速的GUI，用R或者IPython Notebook之类的就行了；但如果你真的必须构建一个GUI，那就用Qt。我本期的工具，惊喜，是一个游戏。这是一个iOS游戏，我每次都想查一下，但我总是忘记它有没有安卓版本。嗯，我查一下。是的，这个游戏叫《Wayward Souls》，它是一个Roguelike游戏，它非常……
much kind of like if we've talked about i think spelunky before um it is on android as well on the google play store yep so in the kind of theme of spelunky or they're saying mage gauntlet but basically it's procedurally generated dungeon levels and you have you can kind of choose what character you want to play as you kind of go into the level you fight some bad guys and you die a lot but then like you kind of get better as like a player you learn what you're supposed to be doing and then like you also kind of get gold that you can use to upgrade your characters and make them better equipped when they go back into the dungeon um and so there's kind of that combination which i personally like where uh you find things in a
很像我们之前讨论过的《Spelunky》。它在安卓的Google Play商店上也有。所以，按照《Spelunky》或者他们说的《Mage Gauntlet》的风格，基本上它是程序生成的地下城关卡，你可以选择想扮演的角色，进入关卡，打败一些坏蛋，然后你会死很多次。但作为玩家，你会变得更强，你学会了该怎么做，而且你还能获得金币，用来升级角色，让他们在回到地下城时装备更好。所以，这种结合我个人很喜欢。
given playthrough that are making your character better, some equipment that you lose when you die, but then there are also some things that you don't lose when you die and you kind of carry across. And I like that aspect as well because it helps me to feel like I'm making progress even when the level is just unusually difficult. Yeah, I've played this game as well.
在一次游戏中，你找到的东西能让你的角色变强，有些装备在你死后会丢失，但也有一些东西在你死后不会丢失，可以保留下来。我喜欢这个方面，因为它让我觉得即使关卡异常困难，我也在取得进步。是的，我也玩过这个游戏。
I think it's great. I like the idea that what you want is you want the suspense. You want to feel such that when you die, you lost significant time. That's what creates the suspense and makes you cautious. But at the same time, you don't want to not make any progress. i mean you don't want to to just never see the ending of the game and so this sort of gives you the best of both worlds yes yep it's kind of like i think there's always this debate like quick save in games like the ability to save anywhere in a game does fundamentally
我觉得它很棒。我喜欢这种理念，你想要的是悬念。你想要那种当你死的时候，感觉损失了大量时间的感觉。这就是创造悬念并让你谨慎的原因。但同时，你又不希望完全没有进展。我的意思是，你不想永远看不到游戏的结局，所以这算是两全其美。是的，我想关于游戏中“快速存档”的争论一直存在，即在游戏中随时随地存档的能力，从根本上……
change how you play a game right and in some ways knowing you can just go back to 30 seconds ago you act very differently than if you know you're going to lose an hour's worth of work but at the same time based on where i am in my life like it's really hard to sit down and know i'm gonna be able to play for an hour and not not quite make it to the next save point and then lose that hour have to do it again next time yeah i mean for me it's okay because uh as you said there's you always make some modicum of progress so you always make some mediocre amount of progress no matter what and so eventually you'll you'll beat the game yeah well everyone's older but wayward souls i
改变了你玩游戏的方式，对吧？在某些方面，知道你可以回到30秒前，你的行为会与知道自己会损失一小时工作成果时大不相同。但同时，以我目前的生活状态，很难坐下来保证能玩上一小时，如果没能到达下一个存档点，就会损失那一小时，下次还得重来。是的，对我来说这没问题，因为正如你所说，你总是能取得一点点进步，无论如何你总能取得一点点进展，所以最终你总能通关。是的，大家都老了，但《Wayward Souls》……
like it's cool and it's you know it's plays relatively quickly and it's not that some roguelikes are very in depth and this one isn't like that and so that makes it enjoyable this is definitely a hack and slash roguelike yep cool all right so we're gonna talk about to source control source control um yeah so basically Control. Source Control. Yeah, so basically Source Control is kind of about just keeping
我觉得很酷，而且它玩起来相对较快，不像有些Roguelike游戏那么深奥，这个不是那样的，所以这让它很令人愉快。这绝对是一个砍杀类的Roguelike游戏。是的，酷。好了，我们要谈谈版本控制。版本控制……是的，基本上是控制。版本控制。是的，基本上版本控制就是关于保持……
they also call it version control. It's about just keeping history of some kind of project. So it's not only about backing up. It's also about being able to go back and forth in time and see sort of, oh, what did things look like, you know, a week ago? Or I pushed out this build and my customers are really unhappy. Let me, you know, go back in
他们也称之为版本控制。它就是关于保存某种项目的历史记录。所以它不仅仅是备份。它还关乎能够回到过去或前往未来，看看一周前的情况是什么样的。或者我发布了这个版本，客户非常不满意。让我回到过去一周，看看哪里出了问题。所以它与备份非常不同，它极其重要，特别是如果你正在进行某种项目的话。其实有两种策略……等等，在你继续之前，我也想说，我认为我们说“版本控制”很重要，因为我们是程序员，但实际上你可以把它当作几乎任何有版本的东西的纯粹版本控制。现在，有些东西不太好用，比如二进制文件很难处理，但如果你有一个配置文件或者……
the past week and see what went wrong. so it's very different than backup it's extremely important especially if you're working on some kind of project um there's really two sort of strategies well wait sorry before you go on i also want to say that like i think that's important we say source control because we're programmers but like you really could use it as just straight version control for almost anything that has versions. Now, some things aren't really great, like binary files are hard, but if you have a config file or...
我正在想一个好的例子。我太书呆子气、太偏向编程了，一时想不出什么例子。哦，如果你在写一本书。是的，就是这样。你可以对你的书进行版本控制。这有点不同，因为我认为在写书时，你总是知道自己在进步。但也许你想回到过去，比如，“我不喜欢我采取的方向”。
I'm trying to think of a good example of something. I'm too nerdy and programming-oriented to think of something at the moment. Oh, if you're writing a book. Yeah, there we go. Yeah, you could source control your book, version control your book. And it's a little different there because I think in a book, you kind of always know you're making progress. But maybe you would want to go back like, oh, I'm unhappy with the direction I took.
我想回到我之前的地方。而在代码中，就像Jason说的，你引入了一个Bug，你需要能够回退。或者具体来说，你发布了代码给客户，他们遇到了问题，你需要能够回到当时源代码的确切状态，并确保你拥有和你发出去的一模一样的东西。这样如果你做了修复，你就知道你到底修复了什么，而不是说，“哦，我在做完一个月后他们给我打电话，我已经加了三个功能，现在我得要么试着完成这些功能并希望没引入新Bug，要么……”你该做的正确事情是能够回到……
I want to go back to where I was before. And the thing in code is, like Jason said, is you introduce a bug and you want to be able to go back. Or specifically, you ship code to make a release that goes to a customer and they have a problem with that you need the ability to go back to exactly what your source code was at that time and know that you're have the same thing you sent out and so if you make a fix you know what exactly you fixed rather than saying oh they called me a month after i did it and i've added three features halfway and now like oh like crud i either need to try to finish these features and hope i didn't introduce new bugs or what you the right thing to do is to be able to go back
你发给他们的版本，在那里修复Bug，然后确保你也把这些修复带到后续版本中，或者无论你的解决方案是什么。这就是版本控制的重要性，它与备份不同，备份只是说“我不想丢失我的工作”。是的，我确实和其他几位作者合写过一本书，我们使用了版本控制。正如你所说，刚开始你只是在写，所以它确实没什么意义，但在最后你要整合这本书的时候，或者即使是你自己写整本书，你也会经历多轮编辑……
to what you sent them and work on the bugs there and then make sure you bring them forward as well or whatever your solution is but that is what the importance of version control is versus backing up which is just saying I don't want to lose my work right and as I did write a book with a bunch of other authors and we used version control and as you said in the beginning you're just writing and so it doesn't really make sense but at the end where you're kind of coalescing the book, or even if you wrote the whole book by yourself, you're going through rounds of edit,
可能还有几位有不同意见的编辑。你经常会发现自己在书的某些部分反复修改，拥有版本控制极其重要。你可能会有一个编辑带你走向一个方向，然后其他编辑决定，“哦，那是个坏主意”。你需要能够回退。所以，正如Patrick所说，不仅是程序员，任何处理源文件的人，甚至艺术家，都有一些专门的工具，它们在对Blender模型之类的东西进行版本控制方面非常强大，它们能处理那些二进制文件，在语义上理解这些文件是如何工作的，并进行有意义的版本控制。是的。对于单个文件也很重要。比如我需要回退这个单独的文件，或者我需要一起回退所有文件，因为特别是对于源代码，文件之间是相互依赖的，所以如果你只回退一个文件，那么……
possibly with several editors who have different opinions. You'll often find yourself going back and forth with certain parts of the book, and having version control is extremely important. You could have an editor that takes you in one direction, and then the other editors decide, oh, that was a bad idea. You need to be able to go backwards. And so, as Patrick says, not just for programmers,
其他文件就无法工作了，因为此时其他文件不再兼容。是的，完全正确。有两种进行版本控制的方法，一种是锁定，另一种是合并。锁定的想法主要用于二进制文件，比如人们在做艺术创作之类的。如果Patrick和我都在为一个游戏制作一堆美术资源，我们只是有一个资源列表。我决定，“好吧，现在我要做草地。我要为游戏制作所有的草地。”我可以锁定草地纹理文件。
anyone who's doing something with source files, and even artists, there's some specialized tools, but they're extremely powerful for doing version control on, you know, blender models and things like that, um, that handle sort of those binary files, um, you know, that, that, that semantically understand how those files work and do versioning that makes sense. Yep. It's also important both for a single file. Like I need to roll this single file back where I need to roll all the files back together because especially with at least with source code right like files depend on each other and so if you only roll one file back then the
当它被锁定时，Patrick可以读取该文件，但他会知道它被锁定了，系统不会让他做任何更改。然后我可以进去，画完我所有的草地。当我满意时，我可以解锁，更新该文件。该文件将解锁，这意味着现在其他人可以锁定它了。它现在有了我的新内容。这样，对于单个文件，只有一个人可以编辑，但你可以编辑很多文件……
other files won't it won't work anymore because the other files aren't compatible at that point yep yeah exactly there's two sort of ways to do yeah there's two ways to do version control one is lock and the other is merge the idea with lock is this is mainly used for binary files for you know people are doing art and things like that if Patrick and I are both making a bunch of art assets for some game, we just have a list of assets. And I decide, okay, now I'm going to take grass. I'm going to make all the grass for the game. I could just lock the grass texture file.
我刚才说，这里的优势在于它让你明确自己在做什么，这样可能更容易避免重复工作，因为我知道Jason在做草地，如果我们都知道草地需要处理，他先动手了，我就知道我应该等他做完。但在源代码场景中，可能是我只需要你给你的类添加这个成员变量来跟踪某件事，但你正在进行算法重写。我不想让你解锁，我做完我的修改，锁定它，然后你再锁定它……
When it's locked, Patrick, he could read the file, but he'll know it's locked and it won't let him make any changes. Then I can go in, I can paint all of my grass. And then when I'm happy with it, I can unlock, I can update that file. And that file will unlock, which means now somebody else can lock it. And it now has my new content. And that way, for an individual individual file only one person can edit but you know i could be editing oh go ahead yeah no you could be editing lots of files but i was
但如果我想做一个小改动，我不想等着你完成你那巨大的改动。完全正确。是的，所以……你继续。哦，不，你继续。我只是想说，这就是基于合并的工具发挥作用的地方，意思是你不锁定文件，每个人都在处理他们的修改，然后基本上谁先提交，谁就是仓库的当前状态。如果你在那个修改之前也在处理同一个文件，那么在你完全让你的修改成为新标准之前，你需要针对两个修改之间的共享文件进行合并。所以，我编辑main.c来添加LED闪烁，Jason在编辑main.c来在启动时添加一条日志语句。我先提交了我的LED修改……
saying the advantage here is it makes it very explicit what you're working on so that it duplication of work is maybe easier to be avoided because i know jason's working on grass and if i know we need we both knew grass need to be worked on, he got it to it first. I know, oh, I should just wait on him to be done. But in like a source control, in a source code scenario, it may be that like, hey, I just need you to add this other member variable to your class to track this thing. But you're doing like an algorithm rewrite. And like, you know, I want to an algorithm rewrite and like you know i want to just go ahead and have you unlock it i'll make my change lock it back and then you can lock it back
他去添加他的打印语句，系统会说，“哦，最新版本比你基于的版本要新，你需要下载新版本，合并你的修改，然后你才能重新上传，它才能成为新版本。”完全正确。所以请注意，要使用基于合并的系统，你必须能够分解文件。这意味着它通常只用于文本。如果你在做某种二进制资源，你会使用基于锁定的系统。许多版本控制系统……
but like if i want to make this small change i don't want to wait around for you to make your gigantic change exactly yep so so that yep go ahead oh no you go ahead i'll just say that so that's where the merge based tools come into play is to say that you don't lock a file like everyone's working on their changes and then basically whoever submits first that's great that's the new kind of current state of the repository and then if you are also working on a file before that change then you need to before you can fully have your change become the new standard you need to merge against any shared files between the two changes so you know i edit main.c to add blink and led jason's working on main.c to add a log statement at boot uh i get my led change
能够自动完成大部分工作，对吧？比如，“Jason修改了第5行，我修改了第33行。”我们会假设这两件事是兼容的，只要它们都能编译通过。我们不会强迫你这个程序员采取任何行动。我们会静默地处理。或者有些工具非常明确，比如“你需要解决每一个冲突”，你需要批准它们，即使是那些自动尝试做正确事情的工具……
in first he goes to add his print statement and it says oh the newest version is newer than the version you based your change on you need to bring down the new version merge in your change and then you can re-upload it and then it can become the new version. Exactly. So notice that like to do a merge-based system, you must be able to decompose the file. And so that means it's typically only used for text. If you're doing some kind of binary asset, you would use a lock-based system. And many of the source control systems
在自动合并之后，它们会给你一个机会，确保在合并提交之前一切都能编译通过，对吧？因为你可能会更改两段不相关的代码。比如我可以删除一个当前未使用的变量，然后Jason在其他地方添加了一些使用该变量的代码，自动合并可能会遇到问题。
are able to do much of that automatically, right? Like, hey, I want to JSON modify line 5. I modify line 33. Like, we'll just go ahead and assume those two things are compatible as long as if both of them were able to build okay. And we're not going to force you, the programmer, to take any action. We'll just do it silently. Or some tools are very explicit, like explicit like hey you need to resolve every change like you need to improve them and even the ones that automatically try to do the right thing
对。因为它认为我删除那个东西与他在其他地方使用它是不相关的。但如果你在做你的事情之前先编译，你就会发现，“哦，嘿，这行不通了。”是的，完全正确。所以，如果你打算使用版本控制，一定要投入一些时间，希望我们已经说服你这样做了。
after they've done the automatic emerge they give you an opportunity to make sure things compile and things like that before you know the merge is committed right because you could change two unrelated pieces of code. Like I could delete a variable that's not currently being used and then Jason adds some code somewhere else that uses that variable and an auto merge could have run into a problem.
花点时间熟悉一个好的差异比较（diff）和合并工具。我用MELD。我觉得MELD很棒。它在过去……我过去用它遇到过一些问题。现在它们用上了GTK3，很多问题已经解决了。但是的，我喜欢MELD，你知道，我并没有……
Right. Because it thinks my deleting of the thing is unrelated to his using it somewhere else. But if you build before, you know, kind of doing your stuff, you'll catch that like, oh, hey, this doesn't work anymore. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. And so definitely invest some time if you're going to use version control, which hopefully we've convinced you to do that.
非它不可，我相信还有其他非常棒的工具，但无论你选择哪一个，都要非常精通它，因为你会经常用到它。此外，还要指出一点，在大学环境或其他地方，使用版本控制确实是可选的。习惯它很重要，它确实有优势，但公平地说，如果你只是一个人在做某事，或者一个女孩在做某事，这没什么大不了的。但一旦你开始有两、三、四个人，它作为一种沟通形式就开始变得非常重要，对吧？去说“这是所有东西的当前状态”，而不是“哦，Joe的……
Take some time to get familiar with a good diff and merge tool. I use MELD. I think MELD is pretty great. It's been up and down in terms of... I've had issues with it in the past. A lot of those issues have now been ironed out now that they're on GTK3. But yeah, I like MELD you know i'm not you know
电脑上有最新代码，所以你需要去复制他的东西，带到你的桌面上，然后做修改，然后Sally需要从你那里拿，因为你现在有了最新版本”，那样效率会崩溃得很快。是的，即使是你自己工作，我也经常处理一些处于早期阶段的原型，我来到一个十字路口，就像是“好吧，我可以在这里做某种机器学习来解决这个问题，或者我可以直接做一个简单的计数”，我不确定该怎么做。所以我说，“好吧，我做计数那个。”然后我做了计数，做了一半，我开始感到后悔，像临阵退缩一样。
married to it i'm sure there's there are others out there that are fantastic but whichever one you pick uh get very good with it because you'll be doing a lot of that so it's also very important to point out that like when you're in university setting or whatever it it is really kind of optional to use versicontrol it's important to of optional to use version control it's important to get used to it and it does actually have advantages but to be fair if you're just one guy working on something or one gal working on something uh it's not a big but once you start having two three four people uh it starts to become very important as a form of communication right to say here's the current state of everything it's not you know oh joe's
我开始想，“哦不，我真的需要在这里用SVM。”但我已经写了一半的计数了。我只是……我感觉不太舒服，但我不想丢失那一半，以防我再次改变主意。对吧？这正是分支（branching）的用途，对吧？你会有一个分支只做简单的计数，另一个分支做某种SVM，你让它们并行进行。所以即使是你自己工作，你也不想删除某些东西，因为你不确定你是否会需要……
computer is got the latest code so you need to go get copy his stuff bring it to your desk and like make changes and then sally needs to come get it from you because you now have the latest version that would break down really fast yep and even if you're working by yourself i've often been working on things that were kind of prototypes that are very early stage and i come to a fork in the road and it's sort of like okay i can do some kind of machine learning here to solve this problem or i can just do a simple counting and i'm not really sure what to do. And so I say, okay, I'll do the counting thing. And then I do the counting and about halfway through it, I feel like, oh, I start having regrets like cold feet.
它，对吧？所以版本控制可以防止这种情况发生。但它确实有开销，而且在我看来，版本控制系统总是有些复杂，因为它并不总是直截了当的，因为它们都有一个围绕其构建的流程，它们假设你在使用它们的流程。而通常你并没有。是的。所以这就变成了你和你的工作方式之间的摩擦。我第一次使用Git时，确实遇到了这个问题，因为我没有遵循那个流程。
I started thinking, oh no, I need to really use an SVM here. But I've already written half of the counting. I'm just not, I just not, I'm not feeling comfortable with it, but I don't want to lose that half in case I change my mind again. Right? So this is exactly what branching is for right you would have you know a branching one branch it just does you know simple accounting another branch it does some kind of svm and you keep them going in parallel and so even if you're working by yourself what you don't want to do is delete something because you're not sure if you're going to need
它们假设了某种流程。然后就产生了摩擦，因为它对我来说没有意义。我只是在念“巫毒咒语”来让它工作。是的。所以，是的。而且我认为还要指出，当你这样做时，工具是针对不同流程进行优化的。
it right and so version control can can prevent that from happening but it does that overhead and version control systems in my opinion are always somewhat complicated like it's not always straightforward because they're trying to they all have a process that they're built around and they kind of assume you're using their process. And often you aren't exactly. Yeah. And so then it becomes like friction between you and the way you do it. The first time I used a get, I really had that problem was I wasn't following the process.
所以像分支，某些工具可能比其他工具更擅长分支，这里的“分支”意味着，就像Jason演示的那样，你有两条分叉的代码路径。比如发布，你可以把发布作为分支。我创建一个分支，这是我的发布分支，我要把它发给客户。如果有Bug修复，我们会在那个分支上修复，但我们会在主线代码上开始添加新功能，这两者可能会随时间分叉。然后可能……
They kind of assume. And then it was friction because it didn't make sense to me. I was just doing voodoo incantations to make it work. Yep. So, yep. And then I think it's also important to point out that as you do this, that there's tools are optimized for different processes.
会有另一个分支用于下一次发布，即2.0版本发布。但你仍然可以给1.0版本添加修改，因为你有需要那个版本的客户。但2.0版本可能人们愿意付费升级并获得最新功能之类的，对吧？你可以把这些作为分支来处理。但还有其他处理方式，比如如果你想为实验性内容做一个分支，然后最终想把它合并回主线，那容易还是难？不同的工具是为不同的用例设计的，根据你选择的工具，你会发现某些事情更容易或更难。这太模糊和抽象了。不，这是真的。我的意思是，我认为你第一次尝试使用版本控制时，它不会感觉很自然。
So like branching, certain tools may be better at branching than others, where branching here means, like Jason illustrated illustrated you have two divergent code paths and like a release you can do releases as version as branches so i make a branch this is my release branch i'm going to send this out to the customer if there's bug fixes we're going to fix them on that branch but we're going to start adding new features on the mainline code and those two may diverge over time uh and then there may
这非常正常。我绝对在许多版本控制系统之间切换过，每次改变都非常令人沮丧。但每次改变，我都很高兴我这么做了。当我第一次从Subversion转到Git时，我非常沮丧。但现在我已经理解了工作流程，我很高兴我切换了过来。是的，所以如果你不打算使用版本控制，就像经典的例子，我们在大学时……
be another branch for the next release the version 2 release but you could still add changes to the version 1 uh because you have customers that need that uh but version 2 maybe people want to pay to upgrade to that and get the newest features or whatever right you can have those handle as branches but there are other ways of handling it too and then how like if what happens if you want to do a branch for experimental stuff and then ultimately you want to merge it back into the main line like is that easy or hard different tools are designed for different use cases and you run into certain things being easier and harder depending on the tool you select that's very vague and abstract no it's true i mean i think that it's the first time you try and use version control it's not going to feel very natural
每个人都在写演示文稿，每个人都有不同的……你们三个人的小组在写演示文稿，每个人写自己的幻灯片，你们都在截止日期前把它们发邮件给一个人，他们试图把它们全部编译在一起，但显然有些幻灯片是共享的，然后一个人被迫手动在中间协调并解决任何冲突。这只是一个例子，但这种情况在源代码中也会发生，版本控制只是让那个过程变得非常明确，这很好。嗯，你也可以像我们已经说过的，回到过去，拥有分支，拥有多个版本，而不必像拥有“main.c.v1”或“main……
that's that's perfectly normal um i definitely i've switched among many version control systems and every time i change is very frustrating but every time i change change, I'm glad I did. When I first went to Git from Subversion, I was just very frustrated. But now I've kind of understood the workflow. I'm very happy I switched over. Yeah, so one way, if you weren't going to use version control, is like the classic, we were in college,
“v1.c”或其他命名方案来处理它。甚至能够将Bug修复应用到旧代码，并且仍然能够将其发送给人们。此外，如果你只是每五分钟对你的目录进行一次快照，那在很多情况下也可能有效，但这会变得非常大，除非你只跟踪差异。但版本控制在构建时就考虑到了这一点，所以它们通常在只存储差异而不是整个文件方面非常高效。是的。嗯，所以也有一些缺点，它不是……版本控制并不能解决所有问题，有些用例它不适用。有一件事要记住，版本控制保留……
everyone's writing a presentation and everyone has different like your group of three you're writing a presentation everyone writes their own slides you all email it to one person before the deadline and they try to like compile it all together but there are obviously some slides which are shared and then a person is forced to kind of like manually go between and resolve any conflicts that's you know one example but like that happens in source code too and source control just kind of makes that that process very explicit which is good um you can also like as we already said uh go back in time have branches have multiple versions and not have to like have you know main.c.v1 or main
整个历史记录。如果你不小心添加了一个100MB的二进制文件到版本控制中，这实际上可能会让你非常痛苦。你应该尽量不要那样做。如果这种情况不小心发生了，你可以使用一些“巫毒黑魔法”来删除该文件。你知道，你不能只是删除该文件，因为它是版本控制，你删除它的事实在那里，历史记录也在那里。你实际上必须做一些黑魔法来回到过去并删除那个文件。什么？你需要清除它。你需要从历史记录中清除它，对吧？没错，根据版本控制的不同，名称也不同，但是的。我想在Git中，它就像是一个rebase，你必须rebase并删除那个提交。
right v1.c or you know what other naming schemes to handle it and even be able to apply bug fixes to old code and still be able to send that to people also if you just like snapshot at your directory every five minutes that potentially could work for a lot of these cases too but that'll get really big unless you are only tracking the differences but the source control is built with that in mind so they typically are pretty efficient about storing only the differences as opposed to the whole files yep um so there are some cons it's not uh version control doesn't solve all the problems there's some use cases where it doesn't work um one thing to keep in mind version control keeps
这并不好看。但无论如何，你必须保留每个文件的整个历史记录。现在，它是压缩的，还有各种各样的东西，但归根结底，它会变得相当大。所以这是需要记住的一点。另一件事是它并不是真正为归档设计的。我的意思是，如果你想保留所有照片的备份，这可能不是最好的方法，因为所有这些流程中都有太多的开销，而你永远不会用到它们，因为你只是把照片扔进去。
the entire history um this can actually burn you pretty badly if you do something like accidentally add a you know 100 megabyte binary file um to to the version control you try should try not to do that um if that happens by accident you can use some you know voodoo black magic to delete the file um you know you can't just delete the file because it's version control like the fact that you deleted it is there and the history is there you actually have to do some black magic to to go back in time and delete that file um what's that you need to purge it you need to purge it from history right that's right there's different names depending on the source control but yeah yeah yeah i think in git it's uh like a rebase you have to rebase and remove that commit.
所以对于那种情况，你想使用我们在开头谈到的东西，比如SyncThing、BitTorrent Sync、Dropbox等等。是的，所以我们快速做一个版本控制系统的“名人录”，我们使用过或听说过、讨论过的，我们将按时间顺序来。所以你会听说过其中一些，很多人听说过CVS（并发版本系统），还有Rational ClearCase，微软的SourceSafe。很多特定年龄段的人的第一次体验……我不知道该怎么说，比如如果……
It's not pretty. But anyways, you have to keep the entire history of every file. Now, it's compressed and all sorts of stuff, but at the end of the day, it's going to be pretty large. So that's something to keep in mind. Another thing is that it's not really designed for archiving. I mean, if you want to keep a backup of all of your pictures, this is probably not the way to do it because there's just too much overhead in all of these processes that you're never going to use because you're just dumping pictures in there.
你在某个时间从事软件工作，那可能是你的第一次接触。Razor……是的，然后我们到了那些都是90年代使用的东西，今天大多数都不再使用了。我的意思是，有可能，但……我说所有那些都是基于锁定的。我不认为大多数不是。基于合并的系统是最近才出现的，并且最近变得更加主流。
So for something like that, you want to use the things we talked about in the beginning, like SyncThing, BitTorrent Synrent sync all of that dropbox etc yep so we'll do a quick who's who's of uh who's who who's who of uh source control systems you know that we've kind of used or heard about talked about and we'll kind of go his you know kind of in chronological order uh so you'll have heard some of these a lot of people heard of cvs concurrent version systems there's rational clear case microsoft source safe a lot of people's first experience that are of a certain age i don't know how to say that like if
对，是的。我不认为它以前那么流行。是的，所以在2000年代，他们有了SharePoint，它也是基于锁定的，但SharePoint针对的是艺术家之类的，所以是微软文档。是的，没错。艺术家、编辑、作家，人们在创作那种内容。它是为团队设计的，其中在文件级别上的协作并不那么重要。它更像是如果你和10个人在写一本书，但你们每个人都在写不同的章节。
you worked in software in a certain time that may have been your first encounter with it razor uh yeah then we get to those were all you all things that were used in the 90s, and most of them aren't used today. I mean, it's possible, but... And I say all of those are lock-based. I don't think most of those aren't. Merge-based is more recent and has become more dominant recently.
那会很棒。SharePoint对那很有用。2000年代还引入了Subversion，即使在今天也非常流行。这就是人们真正开始进行合并和分支之类的地方。Subversion今天被认为是比较原始的。你在Subversion中创建分支的方式是复制整个仓库。所以按今天的标准来看它有点原始，但正如我所说，仍然非常流行。然后最近我们有了Git、Mercurial，这些很有趣，因为它们都是分布式的。
Right, yeah. I don't think it was as popular previously. Yep, so in the 2000s, they had SharePoint, which is also lock based but sharepoint targeted um you know artists and things like that so microsoft documents yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah artists uh editors writers um people are yeah creating that kind of content um and it's designed for teams of people where um you know collaboration on a on a file level just isn't that important. It's really more like if you and 10 people are writing a book, but you're each writing a different chapter.
所以不是有一个中央服务器来保存所有东西，它是以分布式方式存在的，只有通过惯例，其中一个才成为所谓的“黄金标准”。每个客户端都有自己的东西。你可以离线工作。你可以在本地提交，然后上传到远程，即服务器上的一个主机。但这仅仅是惯例，它不一定非得是那个。所以另一个区别是它是中心化的还是分布式的，这有影响。
That would be great. SharePoint would be good for that. The 2000s also introduced Subversion, which is very popular even today. And that's where really people got into merging and branching and things like that. Subversion today is considered kind of primitive. The way you create a branch in Subversion is by copying the entire repository. So it's a little bit primitive by today's standard, but still, as I said, very popular. Then more recently we have like get Mercurial and these are interesting because they're both also distributed.
所以Git和Mercurial都是这两种版本。还有影响。我们并没有真正讨论你如何架构，比如你是否有一个项目或仓库，或者无论你在各种版本控制系统中称它为什么。但基本上，你在什么级别以一种有组织的方式跟踪东西，或者你把它拆分成多个？当你进入一个非常大的团队时，出于性能原因，这也会产生很大的影响，对吧？关于Mercurial，有一点要知道，Mercurial实际上有一些非常酷的功能，你可以检出仓库的一部分。在Subversion的后期版本和Git中，你做不到这一点。
So instead of having a central server where everything is kind of held, it's in a distributed fashion and only by convention does one of them become kind of the gold standard. And every client kind of has their own thing. You can work offline. You can commit just locally and then upload to a remote, one host on a server. But that's only, again, by convention that that is the one. It doesn't have to be. And so that's another difference is whether something's centralized or distributed, which has impact.
你得到的是整个仓库。事实上，Git在底层的工作方式，我不认为它在内部甚至有目录结构之类的清晰概念。但使用Mercurial，你实际上可以按目录设置访问控制之类的。所以我非常支持整个公司使用一个版本控制系统。哇，那很大胆。是的，我的意思是，很多公司都在这样做。Slack有这个，Pinterest我相信也是这样工作的。这只是从和朋友交谈中得知的，但我非常支持这一点。我认为你可以真正信任人们……
And so Git and Mercurial are two both versions of that. There's also impact. We didn't really talk about how you architect, like whether you have a project or repository or whatever you want to call it in the various version control systems. But basically, at what level do you track stuff in one organized fashion or do you split it into multiple ones and as you go to a really big team that starts to have a lot of impact too for performance reasons right one thing to know about mercurial um mercurial actually has some pretty cool functionality um where you can actually check out part of the repository. In later versions of Subversion and in Git, you can't do that.
管理东西，而且仍然必须有一定程度的每目录权限，对吧？你不想让一个团队某天不小心把你的所有东西都删了。完全正确。这就是Mercurial发挥作用的地方。你可以侥幸成功。你可以在Git中使用子树（subtrees）并拥有一个仓库，但在底层，它实际上是一堆仓库。但从用户的角度来看，它只是一个。
You get the entire repository. And in fact, the way Git works under the hood, I don't think it even has a clear concept internally of the directory structure and things like that um but with mercurial you can actually uh set up access control on per directory basis and things like that so i'm a big fan of of having one source control uh system for an entire company wow that's pretty brave yeah i mean well a lot of companies are doing this i mean uh slack has this um uh a pinterest is i believe works this way this is just from talking to friends but uh um i'm a big fan of that i think that um you know you can really trust people are
但Mercurial原生支持目录级别的访问控制列表。所以我正在尝试学习Mercurial。我还没学会。但正如Patrick所说，你可以每个团队有一个版本控制项目，或者整个公司一个项目。架构方式有很多种。
administering stuff and there's still got to be some amount of permissions per directory, right? Like you don't want one team accidentally just blowing away all your stuff one day. Exactly. So that's where Mercurial comes in. You can get away with this. You can use subtrees in Git and have sort of one repository, but under the hood, it's really a bunch of repositories. But to the user's perspective, it's just one.
它们都有优缺点。所以如果你对版本控制的企业级应用感兴趣，这绝对是你想要深入研究的东西。是的。还有我们没有真正讨论的，但所有这些系统还包括它们是否以及如何与你的代码审查流程集成，或者你的公司是否有代码审查流程。这并不总是理所当然的。
But Mercurial natively just supports access control lists on the directory level. And so I'm trying to learn Mercurial. I haven't learned it yet. But yeah, as Patrick said, I mean, you can have, you know, one version control project per team, one project for the whole company. There's many different ways to architect that.
所以，是的，你绝对应该进行代码审查。我的意思是，我认为有另一双眼睛看着某件事非常重要。正如你所说，如果你使用的是基于合并的系统，将合并过程与代码审查过程集成起来似乎很自然。所以这就是GitHub、GitLab、Stash，许多这类版本控制管理系统所做的，它们说，“好吧，当你进行合并时，必须有人批准你的合并，它才能通过。”
They all have pros and cons. And so that's definitely something that if you're interested in more enterprise applications of source control that you'd want to look into. Yep. And then also we didn't really talk about, but all of them is also whether or not and how they integrate with your code review process or whether your company has a code review process. It's not always a given.
那就像代码审查一样工作。是的，但这里的寓意绝对是：不要像我们一样。我们曾经因为没有备份而丢失过东西，也因为没有版本控制或没有使用它而不得不重做工作。
So, yeah, you should definitely do code reviews. I mean, I think it's very important to have another set of eyes looking at something. And as you said, I mean, if you're using a merge-based system, it seems natural to integrate the merge process with the code review process. And so that's what GitHub, GitLab, Stash, a lot of these sort of source control management systems, they say, okay, when you do the merge someone has to approve your merge before it goes through
所以，是的，你绝对应该进行代码审查。我的意思是，我认为有另一双眼睛审视代码非常重要。正如你所说，如果你使用的是基于合并的系统，将合并过程与代码审查过程集成起来似乎是很自然的。这就是GitHub、GitLab、Stash以及许多这类源代码管理系统所做的，它们规定，当你进行合并时，必须有人批准你的合并请求，它才能通过。
and that kind of works like a code review then yep but yeah definitely the moral of the story here is don't be like us we've lost things because we didn't back up and we had to redo work because we didn't have version control or didn't use it.
那样的流程就起到了代码审查的作用。是的，但这个故事的寓意绝对是：不要像我们一样。我们曾因为没有备份而丢失过东西，也曾因为没有版本控制或没有使用它而不得不重做工作。
Since then, we've kind of learned from our mistakes. Hopefully, you guys can learn the easy way through us. Definitely use version control anytime you're writing source code. One thing about Git, you don't need a server for Git because it's distributed, as Patrick said. You can literally just type Git init if you're on Linux or Mac. You probably already have Git installed by default. You can just type Git init in any directory and now you have source control in that directory. It's that easy. So definitely use it for your projects. It'll save you a ton of headache.
从那以后，我们从错误中吸取了教训。希望你们能通过我们走捷径，学到这些经验。在编写源代码时，一定要使用版本控制。关于Git的一点是，正如帕特里克所说，Git是分布式的，所以你不需要服务器。如果你在Linux或Mac上，只需输入Git init即可。你可能已经默认安装了Git。你可以在任何目录下输入Git init，现在该目录就有了源代码控制。就是这么简单。所以一定要在你的项目中使用它。它会为你省去很多麻烦。
And definitely back up your photos. Super important. All right. Well, that's a wrap. Thanks, guys. Cool. One last kind of meta thing here. Oh, so someone wrote in and told us that we're in the top 100 podcasts on iTunes.
一定要备份你的照片。这非常重要。好了，节目到此结束。谢谢大家。太棒了。最后还有一件元层面的事情。有人写信告诉我们，我们进入了iTunes播客前100名。
This is in the US. So I don't know what we are worldwide or in other countries. But thank you guys so much for listening and for your support. And it's truly kind of at a loss for words.
这是在美国的排名。所以我不知道我们在全球或其他国家的排名如何。但非常感谢大家的收听和支持。我真的不知道该说什么好了。
I mean, it's truly remarkable. I don't know how often those change. So by the time this comes out, we may or may not be there. Yeah, we could be kicked off by then yeah we have we have screenshots so we'll send them to you if you don't believe us yeah it's it's i mean like when we started we started this what six years ago or something um just had no idea that i honestly didn't think anyone but my mom and my girlfriend at the time would listen to this. And it's just truly amazing that we've come just so far and we have so many listeners
我的意思是，这真的很了不起。我不知道这个排名多久变动一次。所以等这期节目发布时，我们可能还在榜上，也可能不在了。是的，到那时我们可能已经被挤下去了。我们有截图，如果你不相信，我们可以发给你。当我们六年前开始做这个节目时，我真的没想到除了我妈妈和我当时的女朋友之外，还会有其他人听。我们能走到今天，拥有这么多听众，真是太神奇了。
and we just really appreciate you guys taking some time out of your day to listen to this and we hope that we could provide a good service to you guys. All right. So thank you. Thanks, everyone. Bye. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons
我们非常感谢大家抽出时间来收听，希望我们能为大家提供优质的服务。好了，谢谢大家。再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享许可协议下发布的
Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。